العديد من الاسماء تم تداولها في الحرب
الاوكرانيه الدائره ربما ابرزها كان
يفخيني بريجوجين فمن هو هذا الرجل لنعد
اولا الى بداياته ينحدر بيجوجين من مدينه
في السجن بتهم تتعلق بالسرقه والانتماء
الى عصابه مسيرته التجاريه ارتبطت بتسويق
الطعام وايضا المواد الغذائيه قبل ان يؤسس
سلسله متاجر للبقاله ثم انتقل لعلم
المطاعم وفي عام 2014 اسس بريجوجين شركه
فاجنر اول واكبر شركه مرتبطه بالدوله
للمقاولين العسكريين
للواجهه مجددا في حرب اوكرانيا مع دخول
قوات فاغنر على الخطوه التي اصبحت محورا
اساسيا للمعارك شرق اوكرانيا ومع احتدام
القتال في بخموت قلم مؤسس فاجنر ان
الاركان ووزير الدفاع يصدران الاوامر بشكل
عشوائي
ويطلبان عدم تسليم الذخيره لمجموعه فاجنر
في محاوله لتدميرها بريكوجين كان قليل
الظهور سابقا ليصبح اليوم وجه حرب روسيا
ضد اوكرانيا ما اثار تكهنات حول ايذاء وعن
طموح هذا الرجل السياسي تحديدا ومع صمت
الكريم الكبير يرى مراقبون ان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين قادر على السيطره على كافه
الشخصيات وان بامكانه سحب ريوجين من
الواجهه ليعود لتنفيذ مهام سياسيه لكن من
وراء الكواليس لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات